he calls me at twenty past four this
morning and said all sorry mum I called
you by mistake and as he does silly
things like that sometimes I just put
the phone down and said okay don't worry
but then he called me back again
straight away and said sorry mum I did
call you by mistake and I said okay
don't worry but it bothered me slightly
there was a funny feeling about it and
then when I got up this morning and saw
the news I just knew that he was on the
ferry that was on fire so that's
obviously why he called me but then must
have thought well I won't tell mum
because she'll be worried to death which
of course I am so you haven't spoken to
him since that early morning call I have
I spoke to him about six hours ago he
called me and he was his usual jolly
self and being silly which he always is
because he knew that i would be worried
and they said well I don't have a car
anymore you don't have your ipad anymore
they've all gone and i said if we could
be sake i'm not worried about that what
about you two are you two all right
because he's there with his fiancee and
are you going to be able to get off that
ship and he said I don't know and at
that stage I didn't realize how serious
it was gosh and what did he say to about
the circumstance is about the situation
there in about what help they were
guessing he didn't really say an awful
lot he said that the fire he thought the
fire had started down on the vehicle
deck and that they were all standing
outside and I said but it's just so
awful Nicholas for us we don't know
anything he said well it's an awful lot
worse for us because we're actually
standing out here in the pouring rain
and thunder and lightning and we really
don't just know exactly what's going to
happen and then I suppose he would sense
that I would then be worried and so I've
got to go mum I've got to go mum and and
that's I haven't spoken to him since
did he say anything at all about what
rescue efforts were being made or
whether they were trying to evacuate
people into lifeboats anything like that
nothing he didn't say anything like that
at all nothing and what what's he doing
there because he lives in Greece doesn't
he he works in Greece and he he comes
backwards and forwards and he was on his
way home for New Year with his fiancee
cuz he wasn't home at Christmas so he
was on his way home driving so he was
driving and taking the ferry which would
luck which would be a 24 hour journey
and then driving on to us here through
holland and belgium and so on so yes
it's it's it's a worry gosh a very
worrying time difficult time p we do
appreciate you coming live on to Sky
News to tell us about those phone calls
with you son and we hope fingers crossed
that you do hear good news and he's all
well and safe with his fiance shortly
thank you very much for joining us thank
you